- Job interviews.
- [Job Candidate] Right.
- [Mr. Evans] Nervous.
- So nervous.
- Well, hey, we are the final two.
So,hey, you have fifty, fifty shot,
that's a pretty good chance, of a job.
- I didn't know that.
- [Lady] Mr Evans we'd like to see you.
- Yeah, that's me.
- I'm sorry to have to tell you this,
but we've decided to go
in a different direction.
- Oh no.
(somber music)
- You didn't get the job.
I can provide you with excellent resource.
(sobbing)
- Oh God.
- This is the worst day of my life.
- Oh, thank you again for--
Okay.
- Hey, how did it go?
- I got the job.
Yeah
- What?
- Yeah, he just decided to
give me the job on the spot.
So it was really good in there.
- If I were you, I would just go home,
don't even worry about it.
- I think I should still
go inside and talk to him.
- I wouldn't do that if I were you.
- I just did drive all the way down, so--
- You know what, I just
realized that I forgot my phone
in there, I'm going to go grab that.
I'll be right back.
Just stay there.
Look, I will do whatever
it takes to get this job.
- Mr Evans.
- Please, please, I'm begging you.
I need this job.
I need it.
You don't understand.
I've got some people after me.
There, I said it.
- Mr Evans!
I need a job!
Can I have it?
I'm afraid no.
- Damn it!
Okay!
- Hey, what happened in there?
- Ah the benefits.
We were just talking about all the great
healthcare options I have and I can
finally get that Lasik eye
surgery I've been wanting.
I was just picking up the vibe from him
that you should just go home.
- I think it's worth a
shot, I'm just going to go.
- I forgot what we were
talking about at tea time.
Golf, I forget the number,
it was 9:25 or 10:25.
I'm going to pick it up.
Be right back, stay there.
- Oh come on.
- I'm giving you one more shot.
I'm giving you one more shot.
You don't understand how
much I need this job.
- No, not my, oh God.
- I need this job.
- You have to get out.
- You want to hire him.
You want to hire him.
He looks like he does drugs.
I saw him sniffing before this.
You want to hire a druggy, over me?
Are you kidding me, I want to
do something wild right now.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- Give me the job.
- Hi.
- Hi, I've got a new hiring!
- No!
- Give me it.
- Get me security please.
- Give it to me.
They're going to call security.
- Mr. Evans?
- Hey, what the hell, man?
- I just made partner.
- I heard you slandering me in there.
- I was trying to get you a job in there.
- By saying that I do drugs?
- I did not do that.
I just think you need to go man.
- You know what, I think you're trying
to get me to leave so that
you get the job by default.
- That is not, oh security is here.
That's not what's going on.
I, oh, look at this, this is so funny.
This is what they do to the new guys.
Just hazing the new guy.
Right, I'll see you guys Monday
'cause I definitely got the job.
(electronic music)
Just one more shot!